ah nothing like bacon and eggs in the
morning it's a hearty meal that holds
you together for the whole day it's a
combination so obvious that it's been
around for as long as both foods existed
humans naturally loved these foods
together so they became a staple of
breakfast or did they what if I were to
tell you that the traditional
combination of bacon and eggs isn't part
of our natural history but is instead a
corporate conspiracy orchestrated by
society's Tru puppet masters it isn't a
breakfast for champions it's a breakfast
for sheeple
[Music]
we think that a lot of commonplace
things are the way they are because of
collective free choice when in fact
sometimes one or two people alone made a
decision and created something that is
now taken for granted as part of society
just part of life here's the real story
behind bacon and eggs it all begins with
Sigmund Freud or rather his nephew
Edward Bernays Bernays is credited as
the father of public relations the
product of a time when the world had
become just small enough that you could
manipulate a lot of people at once
because of the way that advertising news
and radio could reach a large number of
people quickly
Bernays took advantage of mass media not
with the intention to inform but with
the intention to control in the 1920s
Eddie Bernays asked a doctor who worked
at his agency whether a breakfast should
be heavy or light and the doctor pretty
much said I guess heavy would be better
Bernays then had that doctor get 4500
other doctors to confirm that all of
them then Bernays lobbied newspapers to
publish that all these doctors were
saying you should eat a big old
breakfast but he wasn't doing this to
improve public health he was doing this
because Beechnut packing company a major
supplier of bacon was paying him to do
it they say that bacon went up and I
still have a letter from Bartlett Kell
president of beech in a packing company
telling me so so we collectively as a
country agreed that bacon was our
breakfast meat of choice but we didn't
freely make that choice at all and
that's just breakfast
our lives are full of decisions that we
think we make of our own free will but
do we these days our markets are
inundated with products and choices but
as having many choices good or bad
[Music]
most people say they like a lot of
choices but do they really we took our
cameras and a few pounds of jelly beans
to Venice Beach to find out first we
invited people to pick one of two flavor
choices it wasn't a choice to make I
chose it because I wanted something
fresh in my mouth
I like it I like lemon and Cyprus and I
think like that
good taste I'm happy with my choice most
subjects were content with their
selection when it was a choice between
two options but what happens when we
offer more choices
well the subjects be just as happy with
their decision
I see North licorice okay connect them
wasn't man
hmm
well I'm kind of regretting not trying a
fruit one because with jellybeans it's
more fruit is more natural I probably
should have gone for my first choice a
raspberry maybe I would there's um I
mean there's a lot to choose from I'm
gonna try one okay marshmallow you're
always questioning like did I make the
right choice right like initially I
wanted to try pineapple but then I
thought marshmallow I don't want to miss
out on marshmallow or peach or blueberry
even if I could choose again I would
probably pick peach pineapple very good
my favorite fruit mmm I could have had a
blueberry which is also one of my
favorites kind of an impulse decision I
kind of wish I looked at the whole thing
a little bit more maybe I would have
picked a better flavor so maybe
sometimes we are actually happier with
fewer choices in fact researchers have
been exploring this idea for years
according to the famous Jam experiment a
study by Sheena Iyengar and mark leper
published in 2002 many similar choices
may even stop us from making any choice
at all the study compared to store
displays one with six varieties of jam
and the other one with 24 although fewer
consumers stopped a sample jam at the
display with limited choices a full
thirty percent of them made a purchase
by contrast only 3% of the consumers at
the more extensive display actually
bought a jar of jam this is called
choice paralysis but life is all about
choices we like having choices don't we
or are we happier when we have no choice
at all
[Music]
hello and welcome to teatime word
scrambles the game show where the
competition is safe and trouble is
always brewing some of our contestants
will be given a choice of caffeinated
black tea or soothing herbal tea and the
others will be given no choice at all
once the tea takes effect they'll be
asked to unscramble some words which
contestants will be happier with their
performance those that have their choice
of tea or those who don't well let's
find out it's tea time my name is
Michael Stevens your host today let's
meet our contestant Giselle nice to meet
you tell me a little bit about yourself
I'm from New York and I've lived in LA
for almost Oh
Giselle you know what that sound means
that means it's tea time go ahead and
take a seat in the tea seat okay well
you're in for a treat Giselle because
today you are going to be unscrambling
words a task that requires energy
because a time limit but it also
requires focus steady calm nerves God
patience yeah so today the choice is
yours you can either have some herbal
tea that will keep you calm and focused
okay or you can have some black tea
that's caffeinated that will give you
some energy hmm black tea yeah all right
go ahead and pour some black tea Trent
you know I'll have some
wonderful no what made you pick black
teeth I want to be energized okay
here's to you cheers Cheers
whoa you know what that sound means it's
word scramble in time remember
this subject had a free choice of which
tea to drink will freedom of choice
bring her happiness and satisfaction
giselle these are your words oh my god
when do I start it well we're gonna put
three minutes on the clock okay go ahead
you can use these steps to access the
letters the goal here is to solve as
many as possible within the three
minutes got it and starting with work
number five is LS kitten that looks like
it could be the right answer
[Music]
vacuum
looking good is up Giselle come on down
and let's take a look at how you did for
number one you got vacuum which is
correct very good job very good job for
number two hearth correct very good job
number three you have TAF rid it's a
very good word but it's not one the
actual answer is a drift so stuck on
that number five you have hidden that
was the first one you solved and kitten
is correct very good job now down here
at the bottom
the answer is lounge you have well
Giselle you received one two three
points so how do you feel you did I
should have probably had the other teas
because I know to calm my nerves I show
you chose the other team this subject
clearly regrets her choice the fact that
she chose the tea herself gives her the
opportunity to second-guess her decision
what about the other subjects who were
given freedom of choice norick we were
looking for ironic no we're looking for
was hard her adrift shroud are these
were actual real words
yeah they are tell me how do you feel
you did today I'm not as well as I had
hoped if you could do it again would you
choose a different team yes you can only
get better you can't get worse than one
I think probably if I'd chose not other
tea I would have gotten everything
correct
none of these contestants were happy
with the choices they make
but what happens when the freedom to
choose is taken away Trin tell us which
team has been randomly assigned to
Athena today Athena has been assigned
black t Oh caffeinated energizing black
teeth here's to you good luck
oh wow that's good tea Athena you've had
the tea we assigned you black tea
caffeinated tea let's see how that
serves you in this challenge
oh boy here are your works you have
three minutes beginning now lots of
choices King finally don't worry Athena
we've had far worse two minutes two
minutes for anything is coming to me
these words are not easy Wow and that's
time Athena come on down and let's take
a look at how you did so forward number
five you have kitten kitten is correct
good job
and for the final work you have lounge
and the answer is lounge very good very
good work so you got two out of the
twelve tell me how do you feel you did
I'm just happy that I got two of them do
you think you would have been able to
solve more if you'd had a calming tea
probably not you need a little something
to kickstart your brain activity this
subject who was given no choice was
happy with the tea assigned to her
despite getting only two words right and
she wasn't the only one how do you think
you did I think I did pretty pretty
great if you could do it again would you
have preferred to have been assigned a
different team no studies have shown
that sometimes we are happier when we
don't have a choice well for two points
you you win nothing this game is
actually more about investigating the
mind so in reality the real winner today
is everyone thanks for playing and
remember no matter where you live or who
you are it's always teatime
damnit I just found another word
so it's not always preferable to be in
the driver's seat of your life sometimes
the pressure to make a decision can
cause you to dwell on the options you
didn't choose and hinder your
performance but what if there's a
difference between the physical process
of making a decision and your
consciousness being aware that a
decision has been made what if all your
decisions are made by someone know
something else a split-second before
you're aware you've made them
[Music]
this task seems easy enough just push
either button before the light comes on
so why is it so difficult Wow
it's difficult because this machine is
actually reading my mind it knows when I
decide to push a button and lights them
up before I can actually push one how
does it feel when it's happening it
feels like like right then it already
knew I'm trying to not have my mind
right here's how the box works my
decision to push a button doesn't begin
when I think it does it's actually
preceded by subconscious activity I'm
not aware of but that the machine can
detect now the machine isn't predicting
which button I will push it's
determining when I'm about to push one
before I know it for the first few
minutes I push buttons in the Box
records my brain activity learning which
behaviors follow which subconscious
processes eventually the box can know
what I'm about to do before even I do in
other words it can read my subconscious
mind and tell me what I was going to do
before I know I was going to do it
that's the part that freaks me out this
is called a free will experiment because
it begs the question of what free will
actually is if your subconscious knows
what you're going to do before you do it
is it really your decision or do you
just think it's your decision Wow
I'm trying to surprise it the
interesting thing is to see that for
instance that you become closer to the
Machine and you definitely speed up
I feel very competitive I don't want my
mind to be red I find this process
frustrating hmm even though I know how
the box works but what if you didn't
know what the box did before you tried
it I want to introduce you to Moran and
this is Diana from the YouTube channel
physics girl one of my favorite YouTube
channels Derek thanks for being here I'm
very excited to introduce you to Moran
Cerf from Northwestern nice to meet you
and he's brought his box Diana and Derek
have scientific minds but they have not
been told what the box really does Moran
explains the deceptively easy game very
simple experiment we're gonna put this
on your head in a second we're gonna
start measuring brain activity then we
would ask you to make a simple choice
which is which button to press if the
lights are on
just don't touch anything so we could
selector on don't touch it
yeah once the box begins to beat they're
conscious decision making to the punch
will they be able to figure out what's
going on a jellyfish amazing good stoked
for the first 15 minutes the Box
calibrates and learns how the subjects
mind acts before making a decision then
the fun begins
[Music]
try to make sure it doesn't both of our
subjects seem increasingly confused and
frustrated I know exactly how they feel
it's hard because sometimes like the
light comes on well I'm going to push it
yeah yeah hombre and you want to tell
him so this box here is reading the burn
activity and tries to predict not which
button you're gonna press at women in
then turn the lights on
just before you press the button this is
predicting when I'm gonna make the
decision what yeah this is amazing I
definitely noticed the lights going on
often when I was going to hit the
buttons but also there were times when
like I wasn't gonna make any choice and
they just went on so I was like whoa how
do you know that maybe the lights just
stop your brain from telling you to make
a choice it's not just oh he's about to
push it but it's he is about to become
aware that he is going to push the
button I'm trying to think like I'm
still trying to how think you like I'm
trying to be like oh I'm gonna push the
left button I'm gonna wait now I'm gonna
do the rushing like what a dumb play
thank you because really it's not about
out thinking us it's about out thinking
yourself
the implications of this are kind of
chilling we could find things out about
you that you didn't know your self work
didn't want to say we could tell you
things like which of these two paintings
will you prefer how do you really feel
about someone imagine using this for
dating because it's reading your
subconscious mind we might be able to
tell that you prefer someone that you
don't actually think you do
well that sounds scary but at the same
time I feel like I don't know I'm such a
human Michael I feel like I have my
human responses like okay there's a
process my brain goes through I get it
you learned it but it's still my brain
is still my process I think what you're
going to write now denial yes I was
gonna use a different word but if you
all go through when we're exposed to the
fragility I'll see you in optical
limitations and by the way we know that
you're gonna have chicken salad for
tomorrow yes that's very clear
like falling dominoes a whole chain of
things has led up to now this very
moment in your life those dominoes might
be your parents your childhood the books
you've read
your friends things that have influenced
you what you had for breakfast how you
felt this afternoon everything has led
up to now that final domino but how it
falls well that's your choice right or
is it
Moran's box kind of questions some of
that if your brain can tell us what
you're going to do before you even know
you're going to do it is your conscious
mind actually being controlled by your
subconscious mind and if your
subconscious can be fooled
then who is actually in charge do you
truly have free will or are you just
like a puppet a puppet who thinks it has
no strings does your conscious aware
self just take credit for things your
unconscious bodies already decided to do
well more research needs to be done but
what we do know is that things you
normally wouldn't consider part of you
are a gigantic part of you I think
Kermit the Frog said it best although
I'm not sure exactly what Jim Henson did
whatever it was it really moved me
[Music]